[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now Fang Corrections this is a segment
where viewers and we've done this a lot
viewers try very hard real viewers look
for mistakes on the show they make a
video they send it in so far we've had
many challengers not one winner nobody
has yet caught me making a mistake well
tonight a fan with the YouTube handle
not FPS fanboy says he thinks he caught
a mistake he says it happened during a
recent comedy sketch we did about Herman
Cain hey Conan watching the show there
and I made a joke about Herman Cain and
free breadsticks from Godfather's Pizza
Herman Cain made the exact same kind of
ads when he was running Godfather's
Pizza yes it's your pizza with a free
order of breadsticks any questions
handle problem with that Herman Cain
step down a CEO from Godfather's Pizza
1996 at that time breadsticks did not
appear on the Godfather's Pizza menu nor
had they ever appear nor would they fear
for another 5 years and that was after
Domino's pizza and pizza had reduced
breadsticks so you were just clearly
wrong on this one
I think I finally got you
well I'm sorry not FPS fanboy but you
are dead wrong Godfather's Pizza did
have breadsticks when Herman Cain was
CEO you think I'm not telling the truth
check out this message from the man
himself Herman Cain are you kidding me
Godfather's Pizza had breadsticks when I
was there just look at this menu from
1993 you see that bridge sticks and what
does it say down here at the bottom
copyrights 1993 looks like I just
corrected you
that'll teach you to shoot a video from
60 feet away using a video camera that's
I think covered in Vaseline yeah it's
like a fisher-price webcam
anyway the challenge still stands if you
think they spotted an error on our show
reported team koco.com / haha i found an
error we will sort it out right here on
the air let's see if you've got what it
takes to make chopped meat out of the
maestro
[Applause]